comme tous les ans et comme d'habitude
au rond-point de la défense
le 37ème salon des arts ménagers s'est
ouvert mardi
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
confort progrès gadgets équipements
ménagers se perfectionne d'une année à
l'autre
[Musique]
jusqu'où cela ira t'il par exemple
pensez vous qu'en l'an 2000 dans 32 ans
votre façon de vivre sera encore modifié
par de nouveaux progrès de la technique
[Musique]
la même chose pour la télé de loin vous
pouvez l'allumé la fermer
vous mettez à poulets à rôtir il ya une
minuterie salars est qu'est ce que vous
voulez de plus je vois moi un robot un
moteur unique et beaucoup de petits
appareils qui se branche sur ce moteur
canon rien faire et laisser tomber les
robots à ma place
rapidement je vois mal nuisances
n'arrivera pas il n'y a pas de machine
qui vous dira aujourd'hui c'est ceci
c'est cela n'arrivera peut-être pourtant
déjà les fabricants d'appareils ménagers
vont plus loin
le film que vous allez voir maintenant a
été réalisée par eux aux états unis à
partir de données précises fournies par
leurs laboratoires de recherche ou grâce
à des appareils déjà existants nous
sommes en l'an 2000 principe de base le
cerveau électronique le centre nerveux
de la maison voici celle de mike w adams
marié un enfant chaque matin contrôle
médical l'oeil électronique fait un
examen complet et détermine
automatiquement l'état général et le
nombre d'exercices de gymnastique
nécessaire et suffisant pour garder la
forme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mike est astrophysicien il n'a plus
besoin de se rendre dans un bureau ou un
laboratoire pour exercer son métier de
chez lui il est en liaison avec le
central de son entreprise et peut
recevoir tous les documents dont il a
besoin pour ces travaux
[Musique]
pour son fils l'école n'existe plus
trois matins par semaine un enseignement
audiovisuel lui et programmer
directement dans sa chambre sur ses
appareils récepteurs indienne à nous
mêmes
qui a inventé le premier télescope
galilée ou léonard de vinci
résultat trois mauvaises réponses nous
vous suggérons de réécouter la leçon 102
à
oh
m
[Musique]
galileo de karine adam ce depuis bien
longtemps ne se dérange plus pour faire
ses courses elle peut consulter de chez
elle le catalogue de ses fournisseurs et
passer sa commande sur ce pupitre sans
se déranger
les factures comme dans l'ancien temps
arrive toujours au mari bien sûr mais
plus vite
il peut à tout moment vérifier l'état de
son compte de ces crédits de son état
bancaire il peut même obtenir
instantanément une photocopie de
n'importe laquelle de ses pièces
comptables
[Musique]
la poste le facteur sont des notions
périmés cet appareil à correspondance
permet de transmettre n'importe où dans
le monde
l'écriture de l'ocs pour les repas la
machine a aussi son mot à dire
elle détermine chaque jour le menu de
chacun des membres de la famille en
fonction du nombre de calories qu'ils
auraient permis
[Musique]
barret mike que dirais tu d'un poulet
salade un hamburger au fromage avec des
frites et une bonne bière fraîche
je vais voir
la machine répond que cela représente
400 calories au dessus de ce qui lui est
permis
elle propose donc un menu de
remplacement rosbif roi salade verte
mais pas bière au caire
elle
m
me
il faut très exactement 2 minutes à
karine adams pour préparer le repas
ou plutôt pour demander à la machine de
le faire
[Musique]
et
les plats surgelés arrive tout seul de
la chambre froide à travers le
réchauffeur à infrarouge jusqu'à la
maîtresse de maison
il n'ya plus qu'à servir
[Musique]
dans cette armoire il y as pour toute la
famille si moi de vivre surgelés
[Musique]
après le déjeuner séances de musique
il n'est plus nécessaire bien sûr de
savoir jouer du piano puisqu'il suffit
grâce à cet appareil électronique
d'appuyer sur n'importe quelle touche du
clavier pour que l'instrument décide
immédiatement de l'harmonie
correspondante
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mike dispose aussi dans sa maison du
téléphone télévision
il peut également consulter la météo
instantanée qui lui permet de choisir
avec son partenaire au golf le terrain
le plus favorable pour leur prochaine
partie non il suffit d'appuyer sur un
seul bouton pour créer immédiatement le
paysage que l'on veut à travers sa
fenêtre
[Musique]
les vêtements à chaque fois qu on les
replace dans la penderie sont nettoyés
automatiquement
[Applaudissements]
jimmy est un passionné d'échecs le
cerveau électronique et son meilleur
partenaire
[Musique]
lorsque le soir on reçoit ses amis sans
distinction de couleur ni de milieu
social bien entendu il est de bon ton de
pouvoir leur montrer sur l'écran murale
de la salle de séjour
le dernier chanteur à la mode on l'avait
préalablement enregistrées sur son
magnétoscope portatif dans une boîte
d'acapulco où d'ailleurs
quoi là-bas navals gamelin
[Musique]
liot
voilà peut-être comment vous vivrez au
21ème siècle
mais est-ce que vous aurez envie de
vivre de cette façon là
[Musique]
moi ma maison dans l'an 2000
ce n'est pas je crois une
cuisine trop presse bouton parce que
disons très compliqué disons femmes les
10 en panne
venir si on fait tout électronique qu'on
manquera un petit peu peut-être pas de
personnalité parce que ça on ajoutera
peut-être je ne sais pas on connaît mal
électronique on parle beaucoup
d'électricité mais d'électronique
stature mais je ne souhaite pas y aller
il y aura plus rien à la veille aura
plus je sais pas moi ce qu'on aura au
moins des meubles oui laurent le petit
lit quand même une fois la l'école
quantique à l'émulation je pense pas
qu'à la maison on puisse remplacer cette
émulation et les enfants ont besoin
d'enfants oui ils ont besoin des
contacts avec les autres vivent les
mêmes ceux de l'an 2000
cette facilité de la vie quotidienne que
l'avenir nous propose est ce que cela
veut dire aussi que nous serons plus
heureux
[Musique]
certainement plus heureux est ce qu on
l'appréciera cela se passait rien la
cuisine quand même je n'envisage pas
demain j'ai simplement des pilules un
visage très bien de faire la cuisine
encore à l'an 2000 et bien le jour où je
ne pourrais plus m'asseoir autour d'une
belle table et au mapic ménagères ne
mourra pas préparé un plat que je
trouverai succulent et électeurs le jour
sur plaisir me manquera je crois que
j'aurais perdu
je ne suis pas contre le progrès il
existe d'accord on doit faire vite
mais attention même au siècle de
l'aéronautique même aussi que de la
fusée qui va aller dans la lune la
cuisine
je suis très fort envers vous et ancien
cuisinier c'est un peu comme au siècle
des diligences
il faut avoir de la patience pour avoir
un très bon je vous signale sud
attention je parle beaucoup je m'en
excuse
c'est à vous maintenant de répondre est
ce que le beignet que vous avez mangé en
gouttes oiseaux
[Musique]